as it walks the fine line between health
crisis and
economic catastrophe the government says
its priority is to save
jobs but the latest figures tell us a
long anticipated
wave of unemployment is finally
beginning to break
unemployment in the three months to
august rose to 4.5
that's up 0.4 the biggest rise in three
years and it leaves 1.52 million people
unemployed we can see the context here
the steep climb of 114
000 redundancies in the last three
months on an
ominously similar path to 2009
following the global financial crash
this printing company in luton one of
the cities where unemployment is rising
fastest
lost 80 percent of its revenue at the
start of the pandemic
it had to make five staff redundant the
boss
fears local lockdowns make more cuts
inevitable
the next step where we're looking at the
work coming in
and the type of work coming in and how
we're going to react to the various uh
sectors that are going to be uh impacted
by the
the next lot of lockdowns is we we will
have to make
probably more permanent redundancies
based on the fact that we've got to keep
trimming and trimming and trimming
now unemployment figures don't tell the
whole story there's a lag in the data
and the furlough scheme is still
propping up the labor market for the
next two weeks at least
but other data offer straws in the wind
like the
claimant count that's the number of
people claiming benefits
in and out of work and it soared more
than
doubling since last year to 2.7 million
that's
one and a half million more people
claiming state support
since march the young have been
disproportionately affected by this
crisis
482 000 people are no longer employed
and 287 000 of them that's 60 percent
are aged 16 to 24. the bleak picture for
jobs is only likely to get worse as
we've seen there are currently
1.52 million people unemployed the
international monetary
fund says that will increase to 2.5
million
next year and that may be conservative
the unforgiving equation is that the
tighter measures to protect lives
the more devastating the impact on
livelihoods